if you're looking for a mattress go with
Helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to 200 off and two
free pillows at helixsleep.com Pacman
so I want to start today with something
we actually talked about on the bonus
show last week we talked on the bonus
show last week thanks to Pat choosing
the story quite frankly I hadn't even
read it which is part of the problem Joe
Biden has quietly almost completely
ended the Drone war that has become
essentially the status quo of American
foreign policy to slightly different
degrees since George W bush through
Barack Obama and including Donald Trump
and the corporate media has barely
mentioned it as we were talking about it
last week I realized we really should be
talking about this more broadly there's
been this bizarre reversal on foreign
policy perspectives
for the Republican Party really since
Donald Trump started running for
president back in 2015 when suddenly
Republicans were pretending they don't
like War
that they don't like military incursions
that they don't like interventionist
foreign policy when really those have
been the Hallmark of neoconservative
republicanism for several decades at
this point in time and if you think back
it sort of started with Donald Trump
saying that Iraq war that was a disaster
Trump started with that and it was
always BS Trump's initial political
constituency was heavily made up of
people who supported the Iraq War under
George W bush and admittedly people who
were sort of right-wing reactionary but
were not really following politics under
George W bush either because of their
age or because they just weren't paying
attention and so they bought it they
bought it hook line and singer Trump and
Republicans now they're against War
um then it went to well uh the leftists
who didn't like Hillary
started building on it with the killery
stuff and the Hillary's going to start
for war stuff and Donald Trump isn't
gonna do that that became the story and
it mostly transitioned right into Joe
Biden's presidency with this idea that
if you re-elect Donald Trump he'll keep
us out of War but if you elect Joe Biden
it means that more Wars are coming Biden
was going to go to war I mean I don't
even remember now Biden was going to go
to war with North Korea and China and
Iran and Russia and all this different
stuff now I said at the time I don't see
any appetite from Joe Biden for doing
those things maybe I'll be proven wrong
but there's another story here that's
actually what we're talking about today
one of Barack Obama's biggest foreign
policy sort of conflicts with my
ideology and I talked about this all all
through the Obama Administration was the
Drone War Trump continued the Drone War
massively he didn't talk about it that
much because remember it was killary who
was going to do the war and the bombings
not Trump but Trump continued Barack
Obama's drone War which was an
escalation of George W Bush's drone War
now maybe Bush would have done more if
the technology had been more mature at
the time Barack Obama had the benefit of
that but now we have the reality and the
reality is that Joe Biden has almost
completely ended the American drone War
Joe Biden's not really saying that much
about it the white house isn't really
saying that much about it neither is
Corporate media but it's a huge massive
story there was that one strike during
the the Afghanistan withdrawal which
went horribly wrong killed civilians
just absolute disaster
but Joe Biden has almost completely
halted drone strikes and air strikes in
general we have to call this what it is
which is a foreign policy victory in my
mind and it's also a Communications and
PR failure by being almost completely
silent about it under Bush we started
droning Barack Obama did even more
Donald Trump continued huge debate
controversy but then look at what Joe
Biden has now done enter's office first
of all sets up a system that requires
White House approval for any strike
outside of a war zone and listen to
these numbers in Donald Trump's first 11
months in office he did 1600 air and
artillery strikes per air wars which
tracks drone strikes in Iraq and Syria
alone air wars reports for under Joe
Biden's first 11 months not 400 not 40
or 40 as Joe Biden says just four four
of them uh strikes in Somalia down 75
from last year to fewer than 10. no
civilian casualties in Yemen instead of
18 strikes last year down to four
this is a massive change but the real
question is why the Biden White House
has been so quiet about it is it because
the Afghanistan airstrike the Drone
strike went so wrong that they just
don't even want to talk about the fact
that there is still some droning going
on is it because it will lead to
Joe Biden being called Weak by
Republicans which of course remember
under Trump Republicans claimed they are
the ones who don't want to do
intervention as foreign policy strikes
War Etc but at the same time the
Republican party has a long history of
pointing to Democrats and saying oh you
don't want to go to war you don't want
to go to Iraq you don't want to take
this person out that well then you're
actually the weak one is it a fear of
that that's keeping the Biden
Administration from talking about this
major accomplishment more
um is it because Joe Biden doesn't like
to brag I mean there's a couple people
emailed me and said they said it's not
Joe Biden constitutionally Joe Biden
doesn't like bragging and that's why
he's not doing it he's sort of he's
bragged about vaccines he's bragged
about I don't I don't think that that's
it so a few different things here number
one of course there's the reality that
sometimes you're droning instead of
sending in Boots on the ground and this
was a big debate early in the big
campaigns under Barack Obama which was
well we may be using drone Warfare here
instead of boots on the ground and if
either way we're going to do damage do
we prefer it be done without boots on
the ground that's not the debate now Joe
Biden's not talking about he certainly
doesn't seem to be thinking about boots
on the ground he's just dramatically
reduced drone airstrikes and we should
be glad about that let me know your
thoughts number one about why you don't
think it's being talked about by the
Biden Administration and maybe just as
importantly number two why isn't the
corporate media covering it but they may
be both related things
um in a scene completely Beyond parody
Beyond satire and also a horrifying
scene I mean it's both
a group of white supremacists staged a
bizarre rally in Washington DC over the
weekend they wore masks as part of their
outfits or maybe we maybe were supposed
to call them uniforms I don't know
outfits is a little bit emasculating
um and thanks to some kind of issue with
U-Haul rental trucks if you can believe
it some of them ended up being like
stranded in Washington DC for hours just
based on poor planning now of course for
me the real story here is once again
look at how this group of protesters is
treated by law enforcement and others
compared to so many others at protests
around the country but we're going to
get to that in a moment uh the story is
that about a hundred members of what is
now called The Patriot front if that
name doesn't ring a bell I'll explain
that as well in a moment a hundred
members of the Patriot front group
rallied in Washington DC near the White
House over the weekend now Patriot front
used to be known as Vanguard America but
they changed their name why did they
change their name well because someone
affiliated with Vanguard America
murdered a woman in that Infamous unite
the right rally in Charlottesville
Virginia so Vanguard America was tainted
now they are Patriot front okay they
were there chanting that they are trying
to reclaim America according to our
friend Zach patrizo from The Daily Beast
their uh outfits or uniforms consisted
of white Gators or masks
sunglasses Blue Jackets khaki pants
brown boots hats shin guards and masks
they also had American flags plastic
Shields that looked really like toys if
you look at the pictures and snare drums
as well now how did police react well
police shadowed the group
apparently to prevent conflicts from
starting and there are some who were
upset that the police seemed to in this
case be protecting the protesters
whereas in left-leaning protests they
the claim is are more antagonistic to
the protesters and are instead
protecting counter protesters now I
think the reality is more complicated
than that uh
and there is much more that could be
said about that
um but the funniest part was the
completely abortive climax to this thing
where dozens of them got stranded there
were there were only a hundred dozens
ended up stranded because they rented
U-Haul trucks to get themselves to the
rally and one of the big trucks couldn't
fit all of them so they waited for hours
as the truck made multiple trips I
genuinely have been unable to find
answers to some basic questions about
this rally did they have a permit as
many of you know
one of the uh it's it's sort of like the
equivalent of resisting arrest for
rallies you know we've talked before how
when police decide
they want to make trouble for a
particular individual or a particular
group this very vague charge of
resisting arrest enters the picture and
it's ripe for abuse along the same lines
when it comes to rallies or protests
whose subject matter some don't like it
becomes well did they have a permit for
the rally I don't know the answer
whether they did or did not why were
they allowed because remember police
were shadowing them as they were
stranded because of the U-Haul truck
issue and the truck was going back and
forth stuffed with these guys
why were they allowed to bring masses of
people around in U-Hauls which have no
seat belts for each person in the back
no padding it's against the law to do
that as well part of the story of why
was this the treatment that these
individuals received rather than fill in
the blanks with whatever example you
want from protests over the last year
and a half sort of starting with
starting with the George Floyd protests
in the summer of 2020. let me know your
thoughts you can find me on Twitter at
dpacman and remember that we've got on
December 14th at 6 PM eastern time we
will be doing the next David Pacman show
viewer Town Hall it'll be streaming live
on the Pac-Man Live YouTube channel
that's the second Channel not the one
that these clips are on it's on the
second Channel and it'll be uh next next
uh what is it Tuesday
yeah next Tuesday Tuesday December 14th
6 p.m Eastern on the Pacman live Channel
one of our sponsors today is Helix sleep
and it's a sponsor I'm thrilled about
because I sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about Helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do I need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your back
pain issues you might have and they will
pair you with a mattress that will be
perfect for you I took the Sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what I needed I often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and I've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so don't get
stuck with something that's not perfect
for you and all Helix mattresses come
with a 10 year warranty and they'll even
come to your house and pick it up within
a hundred days if you don't love it but
I think you will all of my viewers will
get up to 200 off your order and you'll
get two super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video the David Pacman show is made
possible primarily by members who sign
up on our website joinpakman.com we do
an extra show every day for our members
if you like the free show you'll
probably like the extra show you can
also get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show and it really is not
expensive uh and if the normal prices
strike you as high which they shouldn't
but if they did you can use the coupon
code better21 to get a huge discount off
of the membership of your choice at
joinpakman.com uh Donald Trump Jr made a
big splash this weekend tweeting that he
trusts trusts podcast host comedian and
MMA commentator Joe Rogan more than he
trusts Dr Anthony fauci who heads up the
NIH is the top infectious disease doctor
in the United States has spent his
career working on infectious disease now
of course this comes at no surprise that
Junior trusts Rogan more than fauci not
shocking but sadly it's emblematic of a
bigger problem in the United States and
you might say yeah David it's called
stupidity yeah I know I know but I I'm
going to speak a little more
specifically when it comes to Authority
and expertise there is now a particular
problem in the United States
there is a logical fallacy called the
appeal to Authority
appeal to Authority is a fallacy where
one claims something must be true
because it comes from someone believed
to be an authority on that subject now
you might say well authorities on
subjects are more trustworthy that's
exactly the point I'm going to get to
that as I've said before a little bit of
knowledge can be a dangerous thing and
now that these radical zealots heard
about the appeal to Authority fallacy or
they might not even know that's what
it's called but just experts don't know
everything okay they are often quick to
say experts shme experts that's an
appeal to Authority fallacy now of
course there are two important details
about the appeal to Authority fallacy
first of all it's only a fallacy if you
claim that something must be true only
on the basis of a certain person saying
it that then it is a fallacy it might
still be true but it is the fallacy
secondly if someone is actually an
authority on the subject matter
it's not a fallacy
unless again it's the idea that only on
that basis of it being believed that
someone is an expert so given to to put
it away that makes more sense given to
competing hypotheses about some
phenomenon
one from an actual expert a real expert
and one from a layperson absent some
specific reason an evidentiary reason to
believe the expert is wrong airing on
the side of thinking the actual expert
may be the one who's right here is not a
fallacy that's different than the appeal
to Authority fallacy and this is
unfortunately incredibly common right
now on covet the actual experts are
written off by a misunderstanding of
this fallacy now there's another problem
here
the same ignorant people who
misunderstand this fallacy will often
reverse it and they will end up saying
this doctor has the right view uncovered
and it's a doctor so you've got to trust
them and then you'll look and it'll be
like Scott Atlas a radiologist who knows
nothing about infectious disease or it's
a chiropractor which it's a type of
doctor but it's not an MD and it's
certainly not an expert in infectious
disease so that's one layer to this
before I get to the other layer it is
ironic maybe more like disgusting
that the right loves to criticize when
when they know what it's called the
right loves to criticize the postmodern
attitudes of some on the left that
everyone's opinion is valid all
perspectives must be allowed
and on and on something I disagree with
but the right loves to caricature all
the left as believing that and here they
are doing a version of it which is
saying well you've got an infectious
disease doctor okay well that's one
thing and then you've got I don't know
podcast host that's another it is valid
for me to say I trust the comedian more
than I trust the doctor now of course
Don Jr is allowed to say it but when
they say there's an empirical reality
and that's what's so wrong with this
perspective on the left this
post-modernist perspective of it's all
valid listen
well if you're going to be critical of
that then you have to be able to look
Inward and say I'm kind of doing the
same thing here when I say no no no we
must allow Rogan's view to be just as
valid from an evidentiary standpoint as
Dr fauci's they will never look look at
look within themselves they will never
do that now let's get to the second kind
of uh uh problem here
the same ignorant people
who
um uh uh so we've talked about layer one
which is
Junior says he trusts Rogan more than
fauci okay so that's like one layer the
same false Authority applies to Don Jr
weighing in on this and what I mean by
that is there are people in this country
who will also trust Joe Rogan over fauci
because Joe because uh don Jr said it
okay so that this is like a second layer
it's like concatenated expert confusion
or like Russian dolls you know those
Matryoshka dolls one goes inside the
other of expertise confusion Don Jr
misanalyzes the expertise of Rogan vs
fauci on covid and then others in turn
misanalyze Don Jr's expertise on
identifying who's more trustworthy on
kobit and that's where it really gets
ugly so to make an analogy imagine I
don't know see he would never do this
but imagine Sam Cedar said I trust
Pac-Man more than Rogan on MMA
well Sam misunderstanding expertise
because I don't know a damn thing about
MMA and Joe Rogan does but then trusting
Sam
to ascertain whether I or Joe Rogan know
more about MMA is that second layer and
that's what we're talking about and
unfortunately the Trump family looked
upon almost like deities by many in this
country and they are immediately taken
to the idea that well if Don Jr has
assessed that Rogan is more trustworthy
than fauci then that's good enough for
me you get it bottom line is we're in
real trouble that's essentially the
takeaway here we have seen a ton of bad
analogies during the pandemic from
Republicans vaccines are like Nazi
medical experiments conducted by Joseph
Mengele
um vaccine cards proof of vaccination
it's like a Nazi yellow star that they
made the Jews wear during the Holocaust
or last week or the week before we heard
Sherry Tenpenny say vaccinating a kid is
like a very late term abortion because
you're killing the kid with the vaccine
it's a very long list of these bogus
analogies I'm not going to go through
all of it right now but the theme is
absolutely horrifying disgusting
analogies that make no sense whatsoever
we now have another one from radical
rabid reprehensible Republican Ranter
Marjorie Taylor green and this time
she's comparing covid to cancer in
thinking about how societally we reacted
to the pandemic and you might say wait
sir hold on what huh yes she's doing it
Marjorie Taylor green tweeted over the
weekend
every single year more than six hundred
thousand people in the U.S die from
cancer the country has never once shut
down not a single school has closed and
every year over 600 000 people of all
ages and all Races will continue to die
from cancer now of course you all in the
audience because you're so smart because
it's so obvious you realize covet is a
contagious communicable virus cancer is
not contagious
that's the analysis that's that that's
it but there is uh that's there's no
more analogy here but there are there
are some other interesting aspects to
this that I think are worth thinking
about we do spend
is it Millions is it hundreds of
millions is it billions to try to
control the development of cancer to try
to understand what causes it when there
are Cancers of known cause public policy
to try to prevent it I mean you know
we've got a lot of regulations about
cigarettes where you can smoke taxing
cigarettes Etc higher life insurance
cost if you smoke how much pollution
factories can point up uh pump out which
causes cancer Downstream okay at some
level it's because it causes cancer much
more to it of course but we do a ton of
stuff to try to stop cancer which is not
contagious sometimes we do close schools
permanently because of asbestos right so
even when Marjorie Taylor green says we
don't close schools over cancer we kind
of do I mean is what it's just one
example but buildings get shut down
because of asbestos which causes
mesothelioma mesothelioma given that why
wouldn't we do be doing a ton of stuff
to try to stop something like cancer
that kills people
but in this case it's something you can
get from being sneezed or coughed on
covid can also kill you and you can get
it by someone who walks by and sneezes
on you which you can't with cancer and
when I saw this I thought man this is
really dumb but then I thought wait a
second we should be doing more to
prevent cancer and interestingly we have
shut down schools we do do things we
pass significant public policy and then
I realized hey you know what preventing
cancer is really tough especially for
cancers that we don't yet understand the
cause of which is many with the virus we
know the cause we know how it's
transmitted we have a Playbook and it's
a simple one vaccines masks where
appropriate testing sequencing Etc we
know the plan so in the end yes it's a
very dumb tweet
but it's a tweet Marjorie Taylor green
thinks will get us to say wow covet
guidelines these are bad we shouldn't be
doing any of this stuff when you really
think about it layer one is that's
really stupid cancer is not a
communicable disease when you go to
Layer Two it makes me think wow in the
case of kobit we know exactly what the
causes are and still so many people
don't do the basic things to stop it
spread whereas with cancer with many
cancers we don't know what causes it at
the end of the day the problem is that
stupidity does seem to be contagious
people see these tweets and some think
that they're good arguments and they
repeat them and in the end they don't
get vaccinated they don't do the things
that we're supposed to do in order to
stop the spread of this disease now I'm
not even getting into it in this segment
we will get into it
what's happening with kobit right now is
Bonkers and it's not even clear that it
is yet because of Omicron we're going to
get to that maybe later today maybe
tomorrow in the meantime more on this on
our Instagram where you can find us at
David Pacman show you can also follow me
on Instagram at david.pakman we'll take
a quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
so to a degree that is now even
surprising me and I've been following
this for a while
covid is now the Republican virus in the
United States now Liberals are still
dying and we're going to look at the
data in a moment but that's not exactly
the point here
um the vaccine uh uh take up uptake and
mass guidelines have become so partisan
and so skewed politically that the
cumulative death rate particularly since
the vaccines have been widely available
I guess roughly May of 2021
is now a three times higher death rate
in counties that voted 70 for Donald
Trump compared to counties that voted
only 30 percent to Donald Trump this is
it's it's stunning
from a sort of
disconnected analytical perspective and
it's a tragic data set when we think
about the unnecessary life that's been
lost and even if they don't care about
people dying this should be a wake-up
call for Republicans if they care about
future elections listen to this from NPR
since May of 2021
people living in counties that voted
heavily for Donald Trump during last
election have been nearly three times as
likely to die from covid than those who
live in areas that went for now
President Joe Biden we have some of this
data visualized people living in
counties that went 60 percent or higher
for Trump
had a 2.7 Times Higher death rate
than those that went for Biden counties
with an even higher share of the vote
for Trump saw even higher kobit 19
mortality rates for example in October
the reddest tenth of the country
saw death rates six times higher than
the bluest tenth of the country it is
absurd to a degree that is even
surprising me at this point in time now
over the last few weeks the Gap has
shrunk a little bit but in those super
red versus super blue counties it's
still a five and a half times higher
death rate uh absolutely incredible now
let's go through some of the talking
points that you will hear from the right
um mostly the talking point on these
numbers is you've got to control for age
Republicans are on average older
Republican counties are on average older
and the age difference explains the
difference in death rates and the the
responses no it does not
even when controlling for age this is
the trend dramatically higher death rate
in Trump counties rather than Biden
counties now on the other flip side of
this going back to what we talked about
with Marjorie Taylor green earlier the
higher the Trump vote share the lower
the vaccination rate this is not like
cancer even though Marjory Taylor green
said we don't shut down for cancer this
is not like cancer in that
with cancer we don't know the causes of
many types of cancer cancers with many
we do with many we don't many different
types here we know and the trend is
clear more vaccination lower death and
we also see more Trump vote uh lower
vaccination rate these are the Trump
vaccines as they like to say Trump came
up with them Trump wants you to believe
he synthesized to sequence the virus
himself and his voters still don't want
them now obviously we don't know the
politics of the individuals who die a
Biden voter in a red County can still
die and they do
a trump voter in a blue County can still
die and they do but the association here
is Extreme and it even goes beyond this
it is likely on the basis of the lower
vaccination rate among Republicans now
the lowest vaccinated demographic group
in the United States that even the
deaths in the blue counties probably
skewed towards Republicans relative to
their share of the population a lot of
right-wingers call me on my voicemail
and they say David
why are you they don't say David sir no
they just say David or even worse names
um why aren't you talking about how
black people won't get vaccinated and
every time I check the numbers to see
has something changed and it hasn't
black folks do have a lower vaccination
rate than some other groups but it is
still significantly higher than the
vaccination rate among Republicans
Republicans are now the largest
unvaccinated group
there is no single demographic Factor
when you look at gender
race educational level across all of
these being a republican right now is
the signal that you are most likely to
be unvaccinated right now now at some
point
the public health tragedy that has been
this pandemic
could become a political tragedy for
Republicans if they keep going with the
current approach
I'm not giving them advice
my concern is I care about people's
lives regardless of their politics and
as we've said before your decision not
to get vaccinated doesn't only put you
at risk but we're beyond that
if Republicans care about election
strategy you would think that they'd be
saying it's not good for us to
disproportionately lose more of our
voters than they are losing of theirs
I don't know what it'll take to get them
to change their tune there continues to
be a real and serious problem in the
United States regarding access to Mental
Health Services
undiagnosed mental illness untreated
mental illness and over the years we've
covered conspiracy theories and
conspiracism and cultish thinking
cult-like thinking by interviewing all
sorts of different experts and they've
told us about the connection that exists
to mental illness now this doesn't mean
every conspiracy theorist is mentally
ill not at all that's not what this
means but we've explored in detail the
connection that exists there and how
sometimes delusional paranoia and
schizophrenia or whatever it will lend
itself to be captured by whatever the
conspiracy theory of the day is and it
can create some confounding factors in
figuring out what's going on and why
okay
in the last few months
Q Anon the conspiracy group has been
increasingly focused on going out to
Dealey Plaza in Dallas Texas that's the
site of course where former president
John F Kennedy was assassinated in 1963.
and something really interesting and
kind of bizarre developed some of these
people have started to say JFK Jr is
actually still alive
this is this is the late son of JFK the
former president this is an important
detail JFK
and JFK Jr two different people JFK died
in 1963.
JFK Jr died in 1999.
two different people
um this is sort of Fringe even for some
of the Q Anon people like only some of
the Q Anon people believe this but the
idea is JFK Jr still alive now the bulk
of Q Anon is based on the idea that
Donald Trump was
in parentheses sent by God sometimes
it's sent by God sometimes not Donald
Trump was sent
to fight a Satan worshiping group of
child traffickers mostly Democrats among
other things that's the big piece
there's an offshoot of Q Anon that
believes that JFK Jr is still alive
based on I don't even know what might be
numerology hard to understand it so that
gets us to this past weekend where there
was like a it's like it was like a
holiday Q Anon rally paraders of some
kind in Dallas Texas and I'm going to
play a short video here where you're
going to watch and you're going to be
able to hear protesters saying JFK is
alive two people say JFK is alive and
then someone else says JFK Jr too
they seem confused about which JFK is
supposedly still alive and some of them
apparently are saying that it's both
take a look at this insane video
JFK's alive
you'll find out Karen she amnesia
so now JFK is still alive I hadn't even
heard that before
um what do you think is more likely they
don't know the difference between JFK
and JFK Jr and so they heard some cue
people saying JFK Jr's alive they don't
realize that that's JFK's son and so
they're just saying JFK that's one
possibility
the other possibility is
they genuinely believe that it's JFK and
not JFK Jr that's the one that's
actually alive option three is some
other type of confusion that is you know
good good luck figuring out what it is
now again JFK was the former president
assassinated in 1963 if he were alive
today he'd be 104 years old
it's possible
it's not particularly likely even if he
did somehow die in 1963 I'm sorry even
if he somehow didn't really die in 1963
figured out a way to stay alive without
anyone knowing everybody was in on it
nobody spilled the beans he'd be 104
years old today not super likely based
on Actuarial tables for men born in uh
1917 when JFK was born on the other hand
JFK Jr also known as John John he died
in 1999 in a plane crash and would be 61
today way more plausible neither is true
they're both dead but if you're gonna
pause it that one of them is actually
still alive I would go with the guy who
would be 61.
not with a guy who would be 104. no
evidence of either but statistically
more more possible these people are
really confused and to the extent that
they are not violent seeing this is more
sad than anything else the problem is
increasingly there's the concern that
the Q Anon people when none of it comes
true because now they're at years of
none of this stuff coming true
there is the concern
that as their predictions continue not
to come true they will go over the line
into some kind of Jonestown type mass
suicide maybe even taking other people
down with them let's hope not let's hope
not but JFK confusion at Dealey Plaza
over the weekend
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show I have to
tell you there are stories we do on this
show which are extremely
multifaceted in terms of what they mean
geopolitically sociologically all these
different things and sometimes there is
just a story that is too funny at an
absolute basic level you all know about
the big lie at this point I'm sure this
is the lie that Joe Biden didn't really
win the 2020 election Donald Trump
really won it it's something Trump and
his followers have been pushing really
since even before the 2020 election
talking about mail-in ballot fraud
before the election even took place
um no evidence for any of it but then
they really got going with this stuff on
Election night when Trump came out at 2
A.M and said we've basically won it's
over when that wasn't the case and of
course a couple days later it was
confirmed actually Joe Biden is the one
who won the claims range widely
from they stole votes uh digitally with
hackers or who knows dead people voted
the mail-in ballots were fraudulent all
these different ideas no evidence for
any of it of course over the weekend the
former president put out another one of
these unhinged statements which now are
appearing really just on his website
because he's banned on Twitter and he's
banned on Facebook and all of it and it
actually is I would argue I'm going to
propose to you this is the most unifying
statement
that Donald Trump has ever made as a
result of grammatical error quite
there's really no other way to put it
Donald Trump's statement says and I'm
just going to read it to you as written
and then we're going to unravel the
grammar of it you really have to pick it
apart
Trump says anybody that doesn't think
there wasn't massive election fraud in
the 2020 presidential election is either
very stupid or very corrupt
this is a trump statement I can agree
with now let's break it down
um
we you have to really take apart the
grammar okay so Trump says
anybody that doesn't think there wasn't
fraud is corrupt or stupid so if Trump
had said imagine this is the way I
unravel these double negatives if Trump
had said
anybody that thinks there wasn't fraud
is stupid that's really easy you don't
think there's fraud you're stupid
when Trump says anybody that doesn't
think there wasn't fraud Trump is saying
if you believe that there's fraud
if you believe the big lie that's a
double negative you're stupid or corrupt
and that is exactly right it actually
took I was looking over the weekend I
was saying okay so wait if you don't
think it wasn't this is a statement that
I agree with now sure double negative
phrasing is kind of weird
but Trump is finally correct about
something here and this is of course the
ultimate self-owned saved by syntax
bizarrely enough and it's surreal in
some weird way when you think that this
guy had the nuclear codes for four years
could this be the subconscious truth
that Trump actually believes that if
you've fallen for his lies you are the
stupid or corrupt one does Trump simply
have no idea how double negatives work
and in a sense it's the perfect unifying
message if you're able to unravel the
double negative the way we've just done
and you understand it you agree
if you're not able to unravel the double
negative maybe you also fell for the
voter fraud lie to begin with and so you
also agree with this statement it's it's
incredible that he has figured out a way
to really make a unifying statement that
just about everybody will believe and
we're supposed to believe
that he genuinely earned good grades at
the University of Pennsylvania so there
it is if he does get back on Twitter
it will be a very very dark day
um if there are kids watching today
I would send them out of the room before
I play for you what I'm going to be
playing for you right now
I have some cursed video and audio to
play for you today
I don't know how many of you remember or
even knew a very strange factoid which
is that there is a pro-trump movement in
the country of Japan and we've during
previous live streams I played video of
these pro-trump rallies in Japan some
with very strange costumes related to
Trump it's a bizarre bizarre thing but
if you didn't know that
certainly a fact you can get through
life without knowing but alas there is
some pro-trump cultishness in Japan and
there's even an event called CPAC Japan
now CPAC is the conservative political
action conference it's an event at least
once a year I I could have sworn that
some years they've done it twice all
sorts of right-wing speakers it's a Gong
Show of absurdity and pablum for the
right-wing masses well there is a CPAC
Japan the movement in Japan is so big
that they have their own CPAC there it
was this past weekend and this time
around the conference had such
illustrious speakers as Jim Jordan
Mack Warner not even Mark Warner who's a
Democrat by the way Mac Warner
Republican secretary of state of West
Virginia then a whole bunch of other
people I've never heard of and I would
bet money you haven't heard of either
and Donald Trump speaking to them
remotely
Donald Trump recorded an introduction
video for the event it's so bizarre it's
cursed it could give you nightmares
which is why I say don't show this to
children it's scarier than many horror
movies I am sort of likening it too
Silence of the Lambs crossed with The
Shining that's the best
sort of combination that I could use to
describe it so let's look at this short
clip see if you can pick out all the
things that are bizarre about this video
I'd like to begin by thanking everybody
it's been so friendly to the United
States we have an incredible
relationship with Japan and we have for
a long time
like they congratulate Jay aiba the head
of the Japanese conservative Union
they're working together with us and
Matt schlapp and Mercedes slap with CPAC
in the United States has been really a
powerful force our relationship with
Japan has been incredible I worked with
as you know prime minister ABI for a
long time and we worked strongly
together on North Korea and on so many
other problems including problems
frankly with China it was my honor to
help our relationship in terms of trade
has doubled we've gone into a
stratospheric mode it's been really
rather incredible to see what's happened
between the United States and Japan over
the four years that I was the president
of the United States so I'd just like to
say I hope everyone's having a fantastic
time you're with my friends and you are
my friends and congratulations on your
tremendous success I look forward to
being in Japan shortly and when I am I
will stop by and say hello have a
wonderful evening so some truly cursed
images of Donald Trump the camera is so
far from the guy why is that it looks
like some kind of strange horror movie
cinematography the audio is terrible as
usual with these recent Trump videos
there's not even a mic on them the stuff
that he's producing down in Florida they
don't even mic them up cameras 20 30
feet away you can barely hear him he's
in a gaudy Ballroom of some kind he's
wearing a tuxedo he's facing the camera
with his arms down at his sides hinging
forward at the waist the way he often
does everything is weird he's kind of
twitching and making strange body
movements there is nothing normal about
this video but also notable even in this
strangest of strange videos
Donald Trump can't even tell
basic factual truths what was the one
sort of substantive element of that
video
Trump saying we've doubled trade with
Japan
we have not doubled trade with Japan
does Donald Trump not realize that the
data is widely available does he assume
no one will care does he not realize
he's lying I don't know but if you look
and we're putting it up on the screen
now if you look back at the last 20
years of trade with Japan
you see that it's actually been really
steady in 2009 at the sort of bottom of
the Great Recession
it declined but otherwise trade with
Japan has been notably steady there has
been no doubling here and this is
considering both imports and exports so
what's the concern here because it's
very easy to laugh at Trump and see him
doing these weird videos and say oh he's
just a loser past his Prime and he is
and he is tomorrow in fact we're going
to look at video of every once in a
while at his Club Mar-A-Lago they do
weddings at Mar-A-Lago sometimes Trump
will like walk into a wedding or he'll
walk into the dining room or whatever
and he will
um speak to the crowd and often he'll
start talking about the big lie he'll
start lying about the election or
whatever and it's really really weird
tomorrow we're going to look at video
from doing exactly that so it's all fun
and games and the guy's a loser and
nobody's paying attention to him uh in
any kind of serious way but
every poll so far suggests that he would
still win the Democratic the Republican
primary and he would win it easily the
only guy polling even anything of note
was Ron DeSantis when there was the most
recent straw poll and so as much as we
laugh
it would be even more devastating if
again the guy is able to win in 2024 too
many people
when it was Hillary versus Trump
said she's not going to lose she's got
it she doesn't need my vote I'm not
going to vote at all or maybe I'll vote
third party or maybe I'll even vote
Trump as a goof because Hillary's got it
and look at where it got us three
Supreme Court Justices maybe the end of
Roe v Wade one of the most humiliating
mishandlings of code globally and on and
on and on so as absurd as it is to see
Trump relegated to yelling at dinner
dinner guests at Mar-A-Lago or doing
bizarre videos like this most of the
Republican Party based on the polling we
have would put him right back where he
was for four years that's a horrifying
reality hey this is exciting we have
possibly possibly a new top voicemail
caller you can call my voicemail anytime
2192 David P is the number
this guy is straight out of Central
Casting you you've got to listen to this
just no introduction just take a listen
[Music]
right
I mean I listen to you A lot of times I
do listen to you in this
cable thing anyway I'm just calling you
that
you talk a lot of garbage I don't know
it's not like the president talk a lot
of nonsense things that it's all life
same thing with you the thing I
understand how could you not I I'm
pretty sure this is real guys
we uh we we looked up who this actually
is
this is really a guy from where he
sounds like he's from it's it appears to
be completely real
that guy's name Jimmy Carter that may
have been a Freudian slip there
maybe he really does think Reagan was
terrible but he doesn't want to admit it
was people coming off country
and these things are always funny
because you know when you really break
down this guy's a character he's funny
but when you break this stuff down
um the gas prices they have nothing to
do with Joe Biden
when they were low under Obama I wasn't
praising Obama
um when they were high under Trump and
then low under Trump I wasn't blaming
Trump because the president has barely
anything to do with gas prices
um The Border situation has barely
changed since Donald Trump left and Joe
Biden took over you know it it's it's
funny but this this is weaponized
disinformation into this guy now who
believes all these things that aren't
true
this is uh forget he's ruined this
country so bad
that you don't even say nothing about it
talk about Trump all the time Trump you
must be along with this guy
talk about the the president the vice
president got a clown and the Joker they
know they don't belong to [ __ ] in there
they belong in in the clown in the in
the circle now of course not only have I
been so critical of Joe Biden in some
areas that many of my own viewers say
David
you got to be you got to be easier on
Biden
um but I praise the guy when he does
things right like almost single-handedly
ending the Drone War as we talked about
at the top of the show today
this guy is a real clown right he's
worse than Jimmy Carter
we passed a guy
this guy and then you don't talk bad
about this guy oh him we do
nothing nothing I hope I can put this in
the air one of these days now junkie son
you know junkie's not a term I use but
again
Hunter Biden has nothing to do with the
Biden Administration what do people want
me to say
every time I listen to you I'm telling
you don't show nothing like a
I don't know you feel like a guy that
doesn't know what God he's talking about
then don't there's then don't watch you
know I mean as people get upset that
there's so many shows out there that I
think are trash
I don't watch a single one of them
stupid president
a a joke
vice president for me is a joker
I don't know and then you got the other
guy
the the little boy there
I don't know where to get these people
from and you know they were saying
nothing bad about these people who's the
love boy by the way anybody know what
that's about
his country
and I can't stand every time I see these
two clowns who like to break the TV
right in their faces wow you know I
don't wish nothing to the guy but
everybody's not every day with
blood in his head all this Marines being
killed
for no reason
he could have got these guys out no
problems nothing instead he preferred to
kill detecting kids
for no reason
all right okay now we're just it's
gotten very very boring but uh that is a
fascinating caller that is straight out
of Central casting of course not making
a single good political point but uh
certainly saying it in a very very funny
way we have a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about the death of
Bob Dole uh a giant of the Senate 1996
Republican Presidential nominee
um against Bill Clinton in the uh
eventual re-election of Bill Clinton an
interesting guy has passed away we will
talk about Bob Dole
um debt collectors can now text email
and direct message you on social media
debt collector
a very interesting uh profession and I
cringe a little bit at calling it that a
lot of scams in the world of debt
collecting we are going to talk about it
on today's bonus show and also in
addition to learning that Stacy Abrams
is going to be running again for
governor in Georgia as a Democrat of
course we are now learning that David
Perdue the former Georgia Senator
Republican who lost
um to John ossoff
is going to be challenging incumbent
Republican governor Republican Governor
Brian Kemp that's also very interesting
Kemp presumably would be the less trumpy
of the two candidates we're going to
talk about how that race is going to
break down on today's bonus show do not
miss today's bonus show get instant
access by signing up at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code better21 to
save a bundle
and also remember that our members at
joinpakman.com get Priority Access to me
during the upcoming viewer Town Hall
December 14th 6 PM Eastern on the Pacman
live YouTube channel that's it for
today's show see you on today's bonus
show back with another show tomorrow
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors if you're looking
for a mattress go with Helix sleep their
two-minute sleep quiz will tell you
which mattress is perfect for you you'll
get up to 200 off and two free pillows
at Helix sleep.com slash Pacman